my husband and I went on Safari and in a
little Hut was a gift shop and they sold
elephant dung paper and I bought several
pieces and sent them to my pop-up
friends the paper engineers saying well
what are you going to do with this
and so ed Hutchins who was just a great
deer he made this for me
thinking of you this is an elephant made
of elephant dung paper that's really the
circle of life
that's recycling at its best I am Ellen
GK Ruben and I collect pop-up and
moveable books and paper I think I
wanted to know a body of work instead of
a smattering of this and that something
that I could sink my teeth into and
wanting to be an expert on something was
a goal I get contacted by scholars
people doing their theses they come here
they do some research here or they
inquire of me because I literally get it
from around the world of people of doing
research on the flap books or on the
vowels I would go to a cocktail party or
a place where I didn't know many people
and people will say well what do you do
do you work that question was always
answered I do you mean outside the home
and I went to Yale Medical School to be
a physician associate most people call a
physician assistant and then when I was
working outside the home I said oh I do
bone marrow transplants and they
immediately left my side I have to
refresh my drink or something nobody
wanted to know anything about what I did
and so I quickly learned to say oh well
I collect and write about pop up a
movable
and they're instant smile which we
called the smile effect and they would
say I love those books when I have the
opportunity to talk to people about pop
ups there are three things I want them
to know one they did not start in the
1970s the way these Random House books
did and the earliest books and I just
showed you one from 1547 were not for
children they were for adults and they
were used as instruments mathematics
astronomy astrology and medicine this is
from 1933 there are texts describing
what a woman can do to be better sex
partner and so when you say a picture is
worth a thousand words a moveable is
worth so much more to this day every
moveable book is handmade I tell a story
when I was in first grade the class
subscribed to Humpty Dumpty magazine and
so it was for first graders and with
scissors and glue you could make things
and then when we got to second grade my
classmates graduated to Children's
Digest and I refused because children's
died just didn't have things to make I
enjoy doing this but I don't have the
skills that these require and actually
most most conservators do not have the
skill
I consider myself a cheerleader and when
I started collecting publishers did not
put the paper engineer's name anywhere
in the book that seemed to be criminal
because it's not a pop-up book without a
paper engineer and that's where I got
the idea that paper engineers and I
didn't even know the term at that point
but paper engineers are the artists who
take the illustrations and make them
move and that they are puppet masters
but they hand the strings to us the
reader we are the ones who activate
everything who make them come alive
[Music]
my son knows I collect elephants and so
he created this build-a-bear and he
sewed this little pop-up book onto the
elephant and he created this
[Music]